il ya quatre ans minutes physique
stupéfia le web avec un calcul
renversant après quelques manipulations
anodine il conclut que 1 + 2 + 4 pouces
8 puis 16 puces 32 et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à l'infini est exactement eagle au
moins ça ok ce sont déjà les calculs
mais c'est faux créer un faux nom en
fait ce n'est pas s'il faut que ça le
truc c'est que l'infini est beaucoup
plus étrange que le fini j'espère que je
vous en ai déjà donné un premier aperçu
dans les vidéos précédentes
et aujourd'hui on va plonger en plein
dedans nous avant d'en venir à la somme
spectaculaire de minutes physx
revenons-en à la première somme infinie
que l'on a rencontrés sur scène ce forum
dans le tout premier épisode 200 vols
je vous avais dit que la somme 84 tiers
+4/5 mon 4/7 et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
l'infini était exactement égal api et de
l'épisode 2 je vous avais dit que si
l'on écrivait ça c'est parce que l'on
sous-entend que plus on rajoute de terme
à cette somme plus on se rapproche de pi
jusque là j'espère que tout va bien
maintenant accrochez-vous à votre chaise
tenez vous bien tout ce que je vais
maintenant faire c'est changer l'ordre
dans lequel je fais tu cette sommation 4
ou 4 tiers - 4 7e - 4 11e - 4/15 +4/5 -
4 19e et ainsi de suite jusqu'à l'infini
mais maintenant égale au nombre d'or
pourquoi le nombre d'or est ce qu'une
connexion magique entre le nombre d'or
épi pas vraiment en fait j'ai choisi
l'ordre aux sommations pour qu'il soit
égal au nombre d'or parce que le nombre
d'or certain qu'ils aient connu puis
mika et a fait une vidéo là dessus mais
en fait peu importe le nombre que vous
me proposez je peux choisir un ordre de
sommation qui va faire en sorte que la
somme que j'obtiens qui contient
exactement les mêmes termes un cas à 5
min sial va maintenant être égal au
nombre que vous me suggérer le truc
c'est que cette somme ne contient à la
fois des termes positifs et des termes
négatifs et si je regarde uniquement les
termes positifs
si j'ajoute 4 + 4/5 +4 neuvième plus
4,13 à minsk l'infini je vois que chacun
des termes de cette suite est en fait
plus grand que celui qui lui corresponde
ans la somme harmonique 4 les plus
grands que un 4/5 le plus grand qu un
demi 4/9 plus grand que 1/3 et ainsi de
suite
du coup la somme des nombres positive de
la somme initiale est plus grande que la
somme harmonique et elle est donc
infinie de la même façon si je regarde
les nombres négatifs - 4/3 - 4 7e - 4/11
six de suite je vois que chacun des
termes est plus petit que les termes
moins en moins un demi ou incendiaire et
ainsi de suite
or la somme infinie que j'aime écrire
c'est l'opposé de la somme harmonique et
donc elle tend vers moins l'infini et du
coup la somme des termes négatifs tant
aussi vermont l'infini du coup la somme
4 - 4/3 +4/5 -4 7e et ainsi de suite et
une somme tels que si je regarde
uniquement était un positif ça devient
si je regarde uniquement interne
négative ça divergent
on dit que cette somme est semi
convergentes par opposition aux sommes
qui sont absolument qu'on gagne et bien
le fait que cette somme soit uniquement
semi convergentes mais confère des
propriétés très étrange comme le fait
qu'en changeant l'ordre de sommation je
peux la faire régalé le nombreux torts
pour cela je vais mettre les termes
positifs dans une colonne et les termes
négatifs dans une autre colonne
maintenant c'est la somme des premiers
terme et jusque là inférieur au nombre
d'or j'ajoute le plus grand nombre
positif de ma colonne de nombreux
positif al'inverse si la somme partiel
est supérieur au nombre d'or j'ajoute le
nombre le plus négatif encore dans sa
colonne et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
l'infini
on peut alors prouver et c'est ce que
j'ai fait dans cette vidéo en leader que
la somme infinie sera alors exactement
égal au nombre d'heures c'est ce qu'on
appelle le théorème de réarrangement de
rima et ce théorème montrons vraie
différence entre les sommes finis et
seul infinie l'ordre de sommation d'une
somme infinie peut être très important
pour déterminer la valeur de la série
nous ont dit que la somme infinie et pas
forcément commutative voici un autre
exemple de cette bizarrerie en 1655
douanes police prouve l égalité 2 / 1 x
2 / 3 fois 4/3 x 4 5e fois ci cinquième
fois ci 7e et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
l'infini était exactement égal api
divisée par deux ce qui est à peu près
1,57 en réarrangeant les termes ils
voient que l'on peut réécrire la
multiplication infinie en deux tiers au
carré soit quatre cinquièmes au carré
fois-ci septième au carré et ainsi de
suite soit un produit de termes tous
inférieurs à 1
or un produit de termes tous inférieurs
à 1 ça ne peut pas valoir 1,57 qui est
plus grand que 1
encore une fois juste en changeant
l'ordre des opérations on a complètement
changé le résultat est cette bizarrerie
mathématiques a conduit certains à
rejeter purement et simplement
l'existence de l'enfant
mais je pense que ce n'est pas une bonne
raison de rejeter l'existence de
l'infini tout ce que ça veut dire mon
sens c'est qu'il faut juste être
beaucoup plus attentifs faire beaucoup
plus gaffe quand on manipule l'infini et
être prêt à rejeter des intuitions naïve
que l'onda qui sont fondées quasiment
tout le temps sur ce que l'on comprend
du monde fini est en fait si on prend
toutes les précautions nécessaires
on peut même réussir un donner un sens à
la somme stupéfiante de minutes physx
revenons-en donc au calcul de minutes
physique la première chose qui me faut
vous dire c'est qu'il ne faut absolument
pas faire ça à l'école sérieusement
jouer avec les sound infinie c'est un
peu comme jouer avec le feu si vous
faites ça bien vous pouvez faire des
trucs super jolie et impressionné tout
le monde est vraiment prendre du plaisir
à faire ceci
mais si vous ne maîtrisez pas le feu
vous risquez non seulement de vous
brûler au bourgogne m 2 degrés mais vous
risquez aussi de mettre en danger tout
votre entourage
bref faites très attention si vous jouez
avec des sommes infinie chez vous et par
pitié ne fait pas ça à l'école autre
chose avant de plonger dans le coeur du
problème
il est utile au touquet mais utile de
penser que la somme de minutes physique
ce n'est pas juste une semaine classique
c'est un peu une super sonne et ça ça
veut dire qu'il ya des choses qu'on a le
droit de faire avec les sommes qu'on n'a
pas le droit de faire avec les super
sommes par exemple changer l'ordre de
sommation peut affecter la valeur dessus
personne
et puis il est possible d'avoir un
nombre négatif en ne faisant qu'une
super somme que de nombreux positif ok
on peut y aller donc le calcul de
minutes physique qui repose sur trois
propriétés fondamentales de sa super
sonne la première c'est la linéarité
ça veut dire que si j'ajoute les termes
respectives de 2,6 personnes et que je
fais là super somme du résultat
j'obtiens une valeur qui est la somme
des deux super somme initiale donc par
exemple si je prends x est égal à 1 + 2
puisque a depuis suivi depuis seize la
somme des puissances de deux je fais x +
x
j'obtiens terme interne de +4 plus 8
puis 16 32 et c est du coup il a super
somme de
de plus quelques sud puis 16 et c'est ça
va devoir être la somme de x + x
donc c'est égal à 2 x 6 a priori rien de
bien choquant ça paraît assez naturel la
deuxième propriété fondamentale de
lassus personnes deux minutes physx
c'est la stabilité et ça ça veut dire
que si je rajoute 1 0 avant la somme
alors je n'affecte pas la valeur la
valeur de lassus personnes restent
inchangés donc par exemple on a vu que 2
x est égal à 2 + 4 pouces 8 puis 16
puces 32 et c'est bien ça ça va être
aussi égale à zéro plus de +15 8 puis 16
etc
sa part est ultra évident ce que je veux
dire et pourtant je dirais que ce que je
viens de dire si le truc le plus
controverse que toute cette vidéo s'il
ya un truc sur lequel voulait protester
normalement ça devrait être ce que je
viens de dire à l'instant en réutilisant
maintenant la linéarité on peut calculer
2x moins x et l'envoie que le terme à
terme ya plein de trucs qui vont
s'annuler et en fait on va obtenir moins
un plus zéro plus zéro plus zéro plus
zéro etc
et ça je sais par la linéarité que ça
doit être 2x moins x qui est égal à x
donc x est égal à -1 plus zéro plus zéro
plus zéro et ainsi de suite
enfin la troisième et dernière propriété
fondamentale de la super sommation deux
minutes physique c'est la régularité qui
dit que si on a une super sommes infini
qui correspond à une somme infini qui
convergeaient déjà alors lassus personne
doit être égale à la somme et ça dans
notre cas ça implique que x qui est égal
à -1 plus zéro plus zéro plus zéro et
s'était ainsi de suite doivent forcément
est égal à sa seule classique
hélas la somme classique on la connaît
très bien - 1 + 0 puis zéro plus zéro
c'est égal à -11 1 on obtient le
résultat deux minutes physique ce qui
dans sa version plus formel dit que tout
super sommation linéaire stable et
régulière de la somme des puissances de
2 est forcément égal à -1 et là vous me
dites c'est bizarre tout ça mais
n'oubliez pas que la seule raison pour
laquelle on trouve ça bizarre c'est
parce qu'on s'appuie sur notre intuition
de la somme qui une intuition très fini
mais l'infini n'est pas qu'une simple
extrapolation de ce qu'on sait du fini
l'infini est infiniment plus étrange que
le film ceci étant dit je conçois
totalement le fait que le calcul minutes
physx vous reste en travers de la gorge
et vous pourriez vouloir rejeter la
linéarité où la stabilité du coup vous
propose un petit bouquet final qui va
vous proposer un cadre dans lequel le
calcul de minutes physx est
indiscutablement valable écrivons la
somme de minutes physiques sont basses
deux ans besse ii il n'y a que deux
chiffres le 0 et 2 1
du coup les premiers nombres en base 2
s'écrivent 0 1 1 0 1 1 1 0 0 1 0 1 1 1 0
1 1 1 1 0 0 0 et ainsi de suite
je vous invite à aller en savoir plus
sur la base de avec cette vidéo de
wanted a en particulier la somme de
minutes physique sans base 2 s'écrie un
+10 +100 +1000 et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
l'infini
combien ça fait très clairement ça fait
1 1 1 1 1 1 avec une infinité de 1 à
gauche sauf que bien sûr ce nombre n'est
pas un nombre usuelles on l'appelle un
nombre de à dick notamment parce qu'on
l'a obtenu en travaillant base de
généralement selon repères ni peuvent
vous sembler être une pure fantaisie de
mathématiciens et oui car on prend
plaisir à penser à l'hôtel choisi
le plus amusant c'est que ces nombreux
pays indique ont des applications sur
les nombres entiers cancun aussi bien
par exemple les nombres paix a dit qu'on
m'a été utile à un voyage dans sa prof
du dernier tome de ferme
ajoutons maintenant un au nombre de
minutes physx il doit alors posé un plus
à un âge où ton les unités on obtient 1
+ 1 ce qui fait d'eux et embases 2 ça
s'écrit en 0 donc on doit poser le zéro
et retenir le 1
on doit alors à nouveau a ajouté 1 et un
qui fait 1 0 on pose le zéro et on
retient le 1 et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
l'infini si bien que un plus le nombre
de minutes physx fait une suite infinie
2 0 et ça c'est zéro du coup en plus le
nombre de minutes physx fait zéro du
nombre de minutes physx vaut donc moins
je sais que ce résultat a l'air
complètement fou voici une dernière
façon de le comprendre on fait l'égalité
2000 physique c'est parfaitement vrai
modulo 2 mais aussi vrai modulo 4 lèvera
aussi modulo huit modules aux seize mois
due aux 32 muzio 64 et ainsi de suite
en fait il est vrai modulo toutes les
puissances de 2,28 tivement art est vrai
si on considère une classe limites qui
contient toutes les classes de nombreux
modules haut une puissance de 2,7 classe
limite c'est la classe des nombres de
matic
bref tout ça pour dire que si l'on
regarde quelques communes physx sous le
bon angle
les calculs devient non seulement vrai
devient même quelque chose d'extrêmement
profond et révèle ainsi une partie du
mystère de l'origine la leur
on a parlé d'une piste de kart qui tend
vers l'infini et de la série harmonique
et vous êtes plusieurs à m'avoir envoyé
des photos de vos tentatives je les
trouvais super cool donc voici les
photos notamment des tentatives de rémy
rameaux en victoire des et ex bibeau
particulier victoire des a réussi à
s'éloigner de 2,7 car il n'a pas hésité
à faire plus et c'est assez normal de
paris devrait faire beaucoup plus en
tout cas puisque là on est en fait
vraiment proche de la limite si on
regarde on fait la somme harmonique
jusqu'à 204 on obtient 5,87 des six
mètres
d'août 2004 si on regarde en termes de
cartes ça correspond à 2,9 carte donc le
bienvenu 7 on n'est pas loin de la
limite théorique donc en particules fait
qu'il l'ait pas réussi à dépasser trois
quarts de ses frustrations de votre
chaise ça veut aussi dire que j'étais
fait est particulièrement point dans sa
tentative
frédéric tennant lui se demande de si la
différence entre la somme harmonique et
le logarithme de n va tendre vers zéro à
ce qu'ils vont se rapprocher vraiment en
fait
l'orgueil de haine et la somme
harmonique sont seulement équivalent à
l'infini ce qui veut dire que c'est le
rapport entre les deux qui tend vers un
non pas la différence
la différence en fait ne tend pas vers
un elle tend vers une constante
m'appelle la constante doleires
mascheroni donc cette constante on note
souvent gamma et est à peu près égale à
0,57 58 ans comme ça et elle est encore
ultra mystérieuse en partie on ne sait
pas s'il s'agit du nombre rationnelle ou
non ce qui est marrant c'est que ce que
l'on sait sur cette constante ce que si
elle est rationnel alors son
dénominateur à au mois deux cent
quarante mille îles du vent autant dire
que c'est assez normal qu'on n'ait pas
encore trouvé la fraction qui correspond
à ce nombre est ce qu'on y arrivera un
jour où est-ce qu'on arrivera à
démontrer qu'il y ait un signal
on va essayer de le prouver vous même et
j'espère que j'avais aimé cette vidéo
alors il ya des trucs que je n'ai pas
expliqué dans cette vidéo et je les
laisse en fait pour un épisode hardcore
il sortira jeudi
on va vraiment essayer de voir comment
on peut formaliser la somme de minutes
physx pour les nombreux réel et dans un
contexte plus rigoureux la prochaine
fois on m'a parlé de la somme des entier
une autre somme l'infini qui en fait du
bien à mon sens beaucoup plus
mystérieuse que la scène des demandes
physx si vous avez aimez cette vidéo
pensez à la ligue et à la commande et à
la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci au
type heures pour l'automne et j'espère
que c'est un comble à lens marrakech